last night's violent hours-long standoff
ended with no fatalities all six
officers who were shot thank God have
been released from the hospital and just
after midnight the perpetrator finally
surrendered and how did some of the
residents of North Philly how did they
thank their Police Department all right
we'll put the music down now look at
your screen they taunted them they
shoved them again only a few they pelted
them with objects KYW said only 2% of
the hundred percent there 90 percent did
not involve themselves these brave men
and women in uniform ready to take a
bullet 6 Philly police officers took
bullets yesterday to make this
neighborhood a safer place that's the
thanks cops get in the middle of an
ongoing crisis like this a daycare
center across the street these officers
saving countless lives putting
themselves in harm's way and there are
people that are taunting them pelting
them with objects treating them this way
is beyond repulsive frankly just like
the ongoing felony assaults against
police officers in New York City with
water and other objects now and today
here we are less than 24 hours after the
standoff police were forced to respond
to yet another shooting in the exact
same neighborhood five people were shot
today and these brave Philly police
officers back again at work and some of
the most dangerous conditions in America
they deserve better
you know I suspected I was on my radio
show yesterday that something wasn't
right the fact that it was about 9:40
last night in the middle of this program
our coverage on this program we found
out all that time police officers with
people they had apprehended more on the
second floor the entire time and
thankfully they got out safely because
of the good work the diligence of the
commissioner and everybody else and all
law enforcement there but at the very
same time that this standoff is going on
Democrats the media mob they were
exploiting what was an ongoing crisis
from a political gain instead of
actually covering what is serious
breaking news on the ground lives at
stake for example fake news see
before less than an hour into their
breaking news coverage dedicating an
entire segment pushing strict gun
control and less than an hour into the
shooting police officers still ducking
for cover and returning fire there was
20/20 hopeful Kamala Harris in front of
the camera saying this take a look
what's your reaction to these initial
reports and I stress the word initial
report well it's just when will it stop
right I mean part of my focus on what we
need to do around guns smart gun safety
laws is recognize that we have to have
more enforcement around gun dealers well
90% of the guns that are associated with
crime were sold by just 5% of the gun
dealers in the United States and so
among the many plans that I have both in
the form of executive action and also in
the form of legislation one of them is
to put more resources into the ATF to
take the licenses of gun dealers who
violate the law okay senator Harris it
was less than an hour remember this is
at about five twenty six in the
afternoon she's saying that and we had
police officers and people they
apprehended in the building
oh they were there let's see at 9:40 at
night she didn't know any of the facts
on the ground she didn't know that who
the shooter was she didn't know anything
at all about the ongoing standoff she
didn't know there were people at risk in
that same building where there was a
live shooter in there all these people
risking their lives serving and
protecting the people of Philadelphia
Kamala Harris is in the comfort of a
fake new CNN studio Hawking a political
agenda about something she knows nothing
about beyond sick ugly twisted shameful
and as a former prosecutor frankly you
would think she would know better and
several other 20/20 Democratic hopefuls
also yes shamelessly weighing in during
the ongoing standoff they don't even
wait for it to end now
Kirsten Gillibrand doesn't have a
snowball's chance at he'll have ever
been the president blaming the NRA while
bullets are still flying Cory Booker on
Roswell Rachel Maddow is conspiracy TV
our calling for federal background
checks it still wasn't resolved
disgusting sadly not shocking not
surprising all too predictable and we
can't forget last week it was warned
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris they
were literally advancing those old lies
five-year-old lies and conspiracy
theories that had been debunked about
Michael Brown hands up don't shoot an
officer Darren Wilson lies debunked by
one eyewitness after another that saw
the incident even Obama's Justice
Department didn't agree with the
analysis of Kamala Harris and Elizabeth
Warren their Justice Department pointed
out all the eyewitness testimony on the
ground and even now after you know
another shooting Democrats the media mob
they're almost too giddy had a chance
once again to politicize a tragedy very
predictable very sad but think about
this every weekend there are dozens of
shootings in some of America's biggest
cities let's look at the city of Chicago
two weekends last two weekends alone
nearly a hundred people were shot nearly
a hundred people these violent cities
have been run for decades by Liberal
Democrats these cities all have one
thing in common very strict gun laws so
guess what we don't hear a peep from
Democrats the ones that were getting all
upset and raising money off the events
in El Paso and the events in Dayton you
don't hear a peep out of them about
Chicago
it doesn't fit their political agenda
ultimately the left's Astari over gun
control has very little to do with the
people that are being shot in
Pennsylvania for example violent felons
they are not allowed to purchase guns
it's illegal
last night's shooter was a convicted
violent felon with at least a dozen
arrests including the illegal possession
of firearms and aggravated assault and
yet he was in possession of multiple
guns no new law was going to stop him he
had belonged in jail and meanwhile the
shooters in El Paso Dayton they had no
felonies on their records there's no
background check that would likely have
ever stopped them from purchasing any
weapon so this is all feel-good ISM in
the name of stricter and stricter gun
control for innocent people law by the
Americans that have a right to defend
their homes and Families murders illegal
in every single state in this country
shooting people is illegal except in
self-defense
criminals don't seem to care they don't
follow the law by the very nature what
they do like the rest of us and in a
country with open borders guns will
always be available maybe they should
hope control the borders but if
Democrats and weak feckless Republicans
now get their way those of us who follow
the law are responsible gun owners we
would be left totally unarmed and
defenseless once you give away your
rights you're never gonna get them back
on this program for example we had while
2020 hopeful comrade de Blasio the mayor
of New York City he wouldn't answer any
question I asked again and again and
again he had his armed security guards
with him I asked whether people in the
city of New York have the right to have
a gun in their house if God forbid
something happens he kept saying they
have a right to be safe I said I didn't
ask you that do they have a right to a
gun they have a right to be safe do they
have a right to their gun have a right
to be safe that means no he was saying
no in his own way so for them your
rights are not important as long as
they're protected Hollywood stars they
could afford armed security guards